- The 2020 All-Star Game.
- I tell ya what,this is fun.
- This is gettin' good, people.
- As a fan, we love competition
and they are competing right now.
- This is amazing to me
to just see the intensity.
- Everyone is out of their seats.
- I haven't seen this muchexcitement
in an All-Star Game maybe ever.
- It's the 69th annual
NBA All-Star Game.
- You know, you sometimes
takeit for granted.
You know what I mean?
But it's nothing like the
camaraderie being here with
all the guys.
And it's always an honor
and a privilege.
- Team Giannis wearing No. 24
in tribute to Kobe Bryant.
Team LeBron wearing No. 2 on
the back of their uniform in
tribute to Kobe's
daughter Gianna.
- Part of the new format,
eachquarter is worth $100,000
that goes to the charity of
the winning team's choice.
- And here's LeBron whipping
crosscourt. Kawhi Leonard.
Yes! From downtown.
- Back-to-back threes here...
for the Terminator.
- Giannis Antetokounmpowith the stuff.
Now, things have openedup a bit.
[Crowd cheering]
It's a reverse jam!
And on the alley-oop, AD,
Anthony Davis.
- Kemba Walker gettin' hot here early.
- It's a three-point
fest goin' on out here.
- LeBron from way downtown!
- [Laughing]
- Harden with the leap. Beautifully done.
- I can't jump that high.
- Ooh.
- Ahhh!
- Yeah, Luka!
- As Leonard hits his third three
of this first quarter.
Here's Leonard really feelingit. Again!
Trae Young gets it down low.
Yes. Giannis!
- Ooh.
- How 'bout the pass there,
though, from Luka Doncic?
- The lead for Ben Simmons!
- And a steal.
- And he takes the distance.
And off the steal, it's Harden.
Oh, the setup for Jayson Tatum!
- What a pass by Ben Simmons.
- Tatum!
What a beautiful pass.
Jokicwith the setup.
Paul... oh! For Simmons.
And with Team LeBron
winningthe first quarter,
$100,000 goes to
Chicago Scholars charity.
On to the second quarter.
- There's gotta be some type ofsense
of urgency for Team Giannis to get
a win in one of these quarters
to reward his charity as well.
- Giannis is right back.
- And that looked like a sense of
urgency right there!
- [All exclaiming]
- OK, Devin Booker.
- Little bounce.
- Oh, what a move!
- Tape those ankles.
- Kemba Walker!
- Easy. Easy, Sabonis.
- Westbrook...with the leap!
[Crowd cheering]
Chris Paul showing his hops.
- At 35!
- Beautiful pass, and Giannis puts
it down. And he has erupted
here in the second quarter now.
- Look how hard he'splaying, though.
- It's all Giannis here in
the second quarter.
- Oh, the blocked shotthere by Gobert.
- Oh!
And back tap by LeBron, another
opportunity. Leonard for three.
Kawhi Leonard.
- Wow.
On fire.
- He's in NBA Finalsmode right now.
- Kawhi Leonard again.
He's 7-of-8 from downtown.
- No more threes.
- Don't deny me.
- No more threes, bro.
- Y'all gonna deny me?
- Yeah. Box-and-one.
- Lowry off the backboard, and
Middleton with the bucket.
- Did he go through the
legs here? The nutmeg?
He sure did.
- He's done that a lot this season.
- So the Giannis squad leads36-25.
Can't hit the three– oh!!!
It is put down by Gobert.
- That's his range.
- Young from center court.
[Buzzer]
Yes!
But Team Giannis has defeated
Team LeBron in the second quarter.
$100,000 go to the
After School Matters charity.
Third quarter just underway.
And here's Embiid passing ona three.
- Oh, look at this.
- Oh, took a little step or two.
[Laughing]
- Or three or four.
- Kemba Walker right back.
- He's just unguardable.
I don't know what you do.
- I don't know what you do either.
- Giannis! For Embiid.
Well, Team Giannis off to
the strong start.
Here's Kawhi Leonard hitting
a three.
That is his eighth.
- LeBron has a scowl on his face
right now here to start this
third quarter, talking about
the guys,
hopefully amping it up.
- Doncic...for three.
Yes.
And there's a three-pointer by Giannis.
And there's Doncic right back
from downtown.
Another shake-and-bake from Joel Embiid.
- That's a 7-footer, people,
with alittle windmill windup.
- Oh!!
- It's LeBron James!
- What a beautiful
move in the open floor there.
- Pretty pass, and Gobertputs it down.
Nice pass for him-
and Simmonswith the finish!
Trae Young. Oh what a pass!
Here's Young.
You see Westbrook talkingto him.
And Young able to blow by!
- Ohh!
- Simmons hit the floor after
that dunk on the rebound.
- Tatum with the pass there.
- Over the head to Simmons!
- This is an important two minutes
here to try to win this quarter
and that hundred thousand
for your charity.
- And the game is tied.
And Gobert with the stuff!
- This is good. Everyone's up.
- Jokic for three.
Yes.
It's a two-point lead to Team LeBron.
- Are they going to go
for the win or the tie?
- Young—oh!
Gobert with the stuff,
and the game is tied.
As this fourth
quarter gets underway,
the target score:
157. No clock involved.
- And, Reggie, I like this
target score. It's like a pickup game.
- Yes.
- First team to 157 wins the game.
- Westbrook with the finish.
- And Chris Paul continues
the hot hand.
- Team Giannis here struggling
here tostart this fourth.
- Five blue players in the paint.
- Now, these teams are
playinghard right now.
Here's Paul. He's been hot
from three and does it again.
- And look who's getting ready to check in.
The cavalry for Team LeBron.
- Lebron... trying to spin.
- Oh!
- Rejected by Giannis.
- Here's your defense you wanted.
Three hundred thousand's on the line here.
- And Team Giannis up by six.
- And they are, what,
13 awayfrom the win?
- Davis rejected by Giannis!
But Davis right back.
Gets it to Paul in the corner—
and he knocks it down!
Another three.
Team Giannis up by three.
- And look at LeBron James
playing defense right there.
- Play by LeBron
and Giannis went down.
Intercepted by Leonard.
Leonard moving on Lowry.
[whistle]
It is an offensive foul. A charge on Kawhi.
- He finally got it!
- Kyle Lowry finally got
the offensive foul,
something you rarely see.
You got to admit: The intensity
and the level of play has
picked up here in the fourth.
- Harden from the corner...
hits a three.
- Race to 11 now.
- So they're tied at 146.
- Race to 11.
- Leonard
dumps it down low. Oh! A gorgeous
reverse by Anthony Davis.
- To see these guys play with
this kind of intensity,
to go out and compete
on both ends of the floor—
this is beautiful to watch.
- Team Giannis up 150-148.
Leonard with the pull-up.
Yes.
- Team LeBron with a
chance to go ahead here.
- Davis with the stuff!
Embiid backing in.
Nice fake on LeBron by Embiid. Wow.
- Both teams now five away from the win.
- Rebound Embiid.
And Leonard took it away.
- You can't tell me these guys
aren't into it.
Look at the bench.
Lookat both benches.
They've been up this
whole fourth quarter.
- All right. Here's LeBron.
- [All exclaiming]
- Rejected!
They want a goaltend. Let's see.
- The call on the floor
was "good basket."
Is there enough
evidence to overturn that?
This is so close.
- They'll jump it up.
- No basket.
And LeBron cannot believe it.
- Harden. No foul called. And now
we get a call. He hooks—
- [All exclaiming]
- Will not count. Will not count.
Even with the late call.
- Wow. This is unbelievable.
- Back comes Team LeBron.
Again needing a three for the win.
Spins away, and hammers it down.
- That's OK. You're still in the game
if you're Team Giannis.
- Embiid backing James.
[whistle]
- We got a call. Foul on LeBron.
- So, Embiid hits on both.
- And essentially, next basket wins.
- LeBron played by Giannis.
- Captains guarding one another.
- There's a pass to Davis!
[whistle]
And we get a whistle. A foul iscalled.
So, Davis to the line. He can win it.
[Laughing]
- Look at LeBron saying it's over.
- Joel Embiid trying to
get in to Davis' mind right now.
- [All exclaiming]
- Uh oh! Uh oh!
- Wait a minute.
- Misses on the first.
A pressure free throw for Davis.
Oh! Team LeBron has won it.
- But way to make it interesting there,
Anthony Davis.
- An All-Star Game that has to be
considered very successful
because of what took
place in the fourth quarter.
- I loved the intensity
I saw in this fourth quarter.
- But this fourth quarter is probably
one of the best fourth quarters in 25 years.